one habit that i developed when i  when i was at college that was actually  a very bad habit which was  i like to show people that i didn't do  any work  and that i didn't go to classes and i  didn't care and then at the very last  minute  uh like two days before the test i'd get  serious about it  and and people people thought that was  funny uh  you know that was my positioning the guy  who did nothing until the last minute  then when i went into business that was  a really bad habit  and it took me a couple years to get  over that nobody praised me because i  i would do things at the last minute and  and i tried to reverse  to students i'd actually uh i didn't  think that highly of who were always  organized and had things done on time  i'm still working on it but  procrastination is not a good  good habit